herzlich Willkommen zu Donis Tag 16
heute bin ich wieder als Tine witler
unterwegs und warum das seht ihr gleich
aber erstmal begrüßen wir die glückliche
Gewinnerin hallo hi du hast gewonnen bei
dem ausschreiben bei welchem
ausschreiben bei dem ausschreiben wo du
mit deinen Katzen weggehst ach so ja
cool schön dass Ihr da seid ja ach so
das ist schon der kleine raka ah er hat
beim Einschreiben mitgemacht deswegen
warst du jetzt gerade ein bisschen
überrascht er versucht zu flüchten ja es
gibt keinen Weg daraus Romo
so du haust jetzt ab mit deinen Katzen
okay und wir machen drin weiter komm
Timo tschüss viel Spaß tschüss wir sind
heute bei Annie um ihr ein katzenpadise
zu gestalten sie ist jetzt mit ihren
zwei Mietzen zum Tierarzt keine Sorge
reine Routine aber ich habe mir hier was
Kleines überlegt und richtig viel bei
felby bestellt und ja ich habe ein
bisschen Schü davor du kannst aber
bohren oder natürlich vielleicht habt
ihr schon das im Video gesehen mit
meinen Nichten da hat Timo ja auch
gebohrt ich kann ich habe Angst vor
Bohrmaschinen und wir starten damit dass
wir die zwei Kratzbäume rausnehmen ich
hab ihr ein richtig krassen neuen
Kratzbaum gekauft ich bin so gespannt
wie der aussieht und danach geht's dann
weiter mit den Wandelementen aber da
müssen wir uns dann kreativ ein bisschen
überlegen wie wir es machen weil ich
habe es mir nicht so richtig vorher
gedacht aber vielen Dank an dass ich
dich hier komplett überraschen darf und
dass du mir die entscheidungshohheit
gibst let's
go
[Applaus]
[Musik]
na dann holen wir mal das gute Zeug
hierher
zusammen F guck mal ich habe noch mehr
davon
bestellt hier ist noch der Kratzbaum der
ist aber sehr schwer diese Ecke fand ich
auch noch schön also ihr seht das hier
wird wirklich an der Wand das war's
jetzt habe ich alles das werden viele
viele Löcher gebohrt ne vielen Dank an
felby für die Unterstützung dieses
Videos fy findest du nicht nur
Kratzbäume oder schicke katzenwände
sondern auch alles was du für Hund und
Katz brauchst also falls du gerade auf
der Suche bist nach einer schönen
Kuscheldecke einer schicken Leine oder
einem praktischen Katzenklo das alles
findest du bei felbi und damit die
Katzen sich auf eine kleine Überraschung
nach dem Tierarzt freuen können hat
felby auch ein kleines Futterpaket
mitgeschickt ich weiß nicht ob ihr euch
noch an das Adventskalender auspackvide
ern könnt Rumo hat ja diese Cremes
geliebt und ich glaube felby hat's
gesehen Thunfisch Liquid Snack Ente
Liquid Snack für das kleine
Weihnachtsdinner und weil wir immer noch
auf meinem Kanal sind gibt's natürlich
später mit den beiden einen Taste Test
und jetzt starten wir erstmal ich denke
um die Mut zu setten bauen wir erstmal
den Kratzbaum auf und packen den jetzt
erstmal in den Flur da kann ja
eigentlich hier im Flur stehen wie viel
Kratzbäume hat so ein Katzenmensch
schreibt mal in die Kommentare wie viel
Kratzbäume ihr zu Hause habt so bleibt
aber ich finde Kratzbäume sehen
irgendwie cool aus wie ist deine Meinung
zu Kratzbäumen bin broh dass
ich die ganzen Kissen oh wie cool guck
mal hier habe ich an richtig gegönnt das
ist der premiumkratzbaum ganz wichtig
den Karton lassen wir nämlich genauso
stehen darüber werden Sie sich am
meisten
freuen vielleicht weiß der ein oder
andere dass Annie auch meine Managerin
ist und sie hat in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten so viel mit mir gearbeitet
an den adventskalenderv Videos an allem
anderen und ich wollte ihr einfach mal
was Kleines zurückgeben mit der Kraft
von Mariah carry ihrwas zurückgeben
klingt auch so als ob ich sie nicht
bezahlen würde oder ob sie kein Geld
verdienen würde für die ganze harte
Arbeit bekommt sie einen
Kratzbaum wo ist denn die Anleitung ah
sie ist in meiner Hand hier die
Anleitung und jetzt wird gebaut wer baut
der
Haut
[Musik]
so katzenbissind komplizierter
aufzubauen als man vorher denkt also ich
baue lieber ein packschrank auf als
dieses Teil aber das lässt sich richtig
sehen ne Schiggy schigy toll oh das ist
ein richtiges Designerteil weißt du wie
das heißt Silvio Design Katzenbaum Linus
falls ihr den braucht in eurem Leben wir
haben jetzt die Regale rangehalten und
mussten erstmal schauen was wohinkomt
weil die ein bisschen unterschiedlich
aussehen und zu doll gemixt wollen wir
das auch nicht haben deswegen machen wir
jetzt hier das eine Regal hin was ich
noch von zu Hause mitgebracht habe und
da kommt dann die kratzecke hin hier
eigentlich gut ne schön
hoch
und siehst du da die
Löcher da sind so zwei Löcher das ist
Timo das ist der heißt auch Timo heißen
h
Timo Freund das hast Du durch diese
Löcher gemalt ne Sportsfreund super
hammer und jetzt wird gebohrt und das
übernimmt mein
Timo okay alle die Gewehre und let's go
Timo du hast den Bohrer nicht an doch
den hammer hammer ja
okay
[Applaus]
wie weit bist jetzt drin gar nicht ne
nim mal den Achter hier der sieht mir
gut aus welchen hattest du davor den
Zehner ja Bo ist warm gut jetzt Ken wir
rein gar n keine
Chance gar n aber weil es auch nicht
nach Dings was ist das das ist ham das
und das hier
okay h wieder zumachchen ne und sagen
dann gehen wir einfach mit 36
angefangenen
Löchern haben
versucht
ja le okay wir müssen zu Franz geh FRZ
hallo wir waren beim wir waren jetzt
gerade beim Baumarkt weil keine die wir
hier haben hat funktioniert und jetzt
haben wir eine zeig mal jetzt haben wir
ein eigene gekauft ganze gezeigt jetzt
haben wir eine eigene gekauft Makita
gute
warere ein
bohchlaghammer stimmt du hast Hammer du
hast Boher oder du hast halt die Kombi
ich sauge geh rein okay
ja let's
go
boah das ist ein Bohrer
hat funktioniert das kannst nicht
vergleichen du hast recht gehabt das
geht rein wie Butter
jetzt davor war mit Streichholz
reingepit harte
Arbeit aber guck mal wie perfekt das
jetzt hier abgeschlossen das weil ich
Anfang mit dem dicken Kolben reingehauen
hab kling
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
pervers also hinten W wir eigentlich
noch eine Wand ran machen wollten ist
Stahl und dafür haben wir keinen Bohrer
gekauft wir haben nur ein Betonbohrer
gekauft
also machen wir jetzt hier noch
erweitern wir die Kletterwand in die
Richtung das haben wir uns gut überlegt
das ist nicht spontan entschieden hey
ist das schief sieht doch schief aus
jetzt würde ich den wieder auf dieser
Höhe machen ne wieer andere oder
hier
auch wieder
[Musik]
was God dam so es ist jetzt 13 Uhr wir
dürfen nicht mehr Bohen das heißt jetzt
wird nur noch rangeschraubt ganz leise
an ist schon nach Hause gekommen wir
haben viel zu lange gebraucht kannst du
gleich trotzdem so faken wie du
[Musik]
reagierst
ich habe mir eine richtig coole reaction
gedacht dass Annie vom Tierarzt kommt
und dann die kratzwände sieht und den
Kratzbaum und sich denkt wow aber dann
kam sie viel früher als gedacht und wir
haben viel länger gebraucht als gedacht
also faken wir jetzt eine reaction Ani
bist du bereit für deine neue kratzwand
ja komm
rein sagst du bescheid wenn ich
aufmachen darf Hollywood
okay wo wo
3 2
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wow
das ist das schönste was ich mir jeemils
hätte vorstellen können das habe ich mir
schon immer gewünscht oh der kratzb wie
toll der aussieht deine kanatze oh guck
mal Susi wir sind gerade erst vom Tier
wieder bekommen und du hast so eine
tolle Überraschung bekommen hast du das
schon gesehen möchtest du was davon
probieren nee die Gutscheine brauchst du
nicht deine Mama hat genug bekommen oh
das ist wirklich schön das habt ihr
richtig toll gemacht meinst du es wird
Dir gut gefallen ja ich glaube das wird
dir sehr gut gefallen willst du darauf
kletter hoch l mal
probieren wow t hat gesagt sie muss auch
ein bisschen abnehmen oh habt ihr da was
extra gemacht für die Katzen damit sie
da was zum Spielen haben genau das ist
so eine neue Art guck wie sie sie das
findet ja da
wird nein es ist wirklich sehr schön die
Ecke da hinten gefällt mir auch richtig
gut und so haben die Katzen Möglichkeit
in einem sicheren spot alles zu
überblicken der ist wirklich Premium der
ist richtig richtig schön also ja der
ist halt einfach auch ein bisschen
stylisch steilisch den alten haben sie
auch echt nur diese eine Dings benutzt
und ansonsten ist der echt nur
eingestaubt und jetzt ist da halt voll
die schön Integration und die können
hier einfach die ganze Wand lang hoch
und runter klettern guck mal su sie hat
das schon gut angenommen da hinten da
wird sich schon der Fuß gelckt die lebt
die Ecke ja also die Katzen würden
sicherlich Danke sagen wenn sie sprechen
könnten aber deswegen sage ich Danke
Timo danke Vanessa und danke
felby ja und jetzt
probieren wir noch ein bisschen was ich
habe ihn was von felby mitgebracht denn
weißt du was die felby Snacks sind nicht
nur lecker sondern auch gesund oh da z.B
Getreide und zuckerfrei 100% natürlich
was wollen wir da mal verfüttern
ich glaube lass uns mal Ente nehmen und
von dem anderen nehmen wir tunf und
solange an jetzt das Abendmal für die
Katzen zubereitet wollte ich euch noch
sagen dass ich übrigens einen Rabattcode
habe malwanne für 15% im Shop unten
findet ihr den Link da kommt ihr direkt
zu felbi und dort gibt es nicht nur
Katzen und hundezeug sondern auch für
den Zweibeiner z.B outdoorware also
alles was man so braucht wenn man
draußen mit seinem Tierchen unterwegs
ist ich z.B mit meinem Hamster da habe
ich immer eine ganz praktische Hose an
und so wir spielen immer
Schlamm nicht nur essen du sollst auch
[Musik]
bewerten na ja anscheinend schmeckt ihm
bis
morgen hat wirklich Spaß gemacht ne ja
wirklich sehr aber es war schon be all
en Projekten ich mein Timo also unser
Team hier ja das haben wir schon oft
gemacht und immer sagen wir ja halber
Tag ein Tag es wird meistens dann D Tage
aus 12 Uhr wurde 15:30 uh ja so ich
glaube das ist einfach auch wieder ein
Learning aber ansonsten sind wir hier
tolles Team TT ja finde ich auch wir
sind echt ein tolles Team und ich find
es lustig wie viele Sachen wir schon so
gemeinsam handwerklich gemacht haben
also eigentlich viel zu viele warum tun
wir das so oftst kommt der Diamant Stahl
wir haben uns heute eine Bohrmaschine
gekauft eigene haben wir jetzt ja wir
haben eine bürobohrmaschine eine die wir
von der Steuer absetzen
yay ja ich fin's aber auch richtig schön
geworden jetzt es gefällt mir total gut
und dann sehen wir uns jetzt morgen
wieder ne tschüss ah ne wir uns nicht
wir uns nicht wir machen jetzt Pause wir
haben zwei Tage das reicht ja aber wir
sehen uns morgen wieder und morgen gehen
wir unsere Hochzeitslocation
anschauen